翻訳: Kouki Okawara
校正: Hiroko Kawano
作業着の兄ちゃんが出てきて
驚いた人もいるんじゃないでしょうか？
焼けた肌 刈り上げた頭
そしてニッカボッカ
「おいおい ここは現場じゃねぇぞ
本当に この兄ちゃんが
これから
クリエイティブなスピーチなんか
できるんだろうか？」
そんな風に思った人がいたら
ちょっと手を挙げてみてください
（笑）
思いの外 少ないから
１つアイディアが出てきました
優しさって 時には残酷です
（笑）
みんなが気を遣ってくれたんだけど
このあとに用意していたトークが
みんな台無しです
（笑）
分かりました
やるしかないんでやります
聞いてください
S君 —
彼は 家庭の事情で
小学校１年生の時に
おじいちゃんとおばあちゃんに
預けられました
彼のおじいちゃんは いわゆる企業戦士
寝る間も惜しんで 朝早くから夜遅くまで
働いていたそうです
そして彼のおばあちゃんは
免許がなかったので
自転車で行ける範囲内で
生活をしていたそうです
彼の通っていた学校は
家から歩いて約２時間半の道のり
小学校１年生が
歩いて行ける距離ではないので
おじいちゃんが通勤途中に 学校の前に
校門の前に降ろしていたそうです
なんと朝５時半に
想像してください
真冬の寒い中 朝の５時半
学校の校門の前で
体育座りをして待っている子供の姿を
しかし ここまでの話を聞いて
悲観的には思わないでください
彼は今も すごく元気にやっています
なぜなら こんなに素晴らしい舞台で
みなさんの前で
スピーチができるようにまでなりました
（拍手）
私自身の話でした
後から じいちゃんに聞いたら
俺を校門の前に降ろす時に
「あー かわいそうだな」って
後ろ髪引かれながら
通勤していたそうです
人とはちょっと違ったけど
俺は愛されていたんだと思います
育っていく過程で 人には言えない
人よりたくさん悪いことしてきたけど
今では２人の子供のパパ
愛する妻と仲睦まじい家庭を築き
２つ会社を経営して
１つカフェのオーナーをしています
そして 地域の青年団体でまちづくりや
ボランティア活動にも参加しています
ここまでの話を聞くと
苦難を乗り越えて 順風満帆
そんな風に見えるかもしれませんが
今でも 昔のことを思い出すと
心の中がぎゅーって痛くなることがあります
「傷はいつか癒える」
そんな言葉があるけど それは絶対嘘
子供の頃に受けた心の傷は
忘れることがあっても
消えることはないんです
これは辛い体験をした子供にしか
分からないかもしれません
今でもなお そんな想いがあるからこそ
僕は 子供たちが
すごく心配でなりません
そして 会社経営をする傍で
更生保護活動というものに力を入れています
この活動は いわゆる不良少年や
家庭に恵まれない子供たち
虐待 育児放棄
経済的理由で親と住めない子
死別といったケースもあります
そんな子供たちの心に寄り添う活動です
そして この活動をしていく中で
R君という少年に出会いました
彼は１歳の頃 家庭の事情で
おばあちゃんに預けられました
彼のおばあちゃんは とっても優しくて
いつも一生懸命面倒を見てくれる
彼はおばあちゃんが大好きでした
そんな幸せな毎日が続くと思った
小学校５年生の頃
彼のおばあちゃんは
自殺してしまいました
理由は分かりません
悲しみに打ちひしがれそうになりながらも
生みのお母さんと
新しくできていたお父さんと
新しくできていた妹と
暮らしを始めるようになりました
この寂しさが なんとか紛れないかなと
和やかな家庭生活を想像していた
彼に 訪れた現実は
アルコール中毒で
大声を出して暴れるお母さん
彼のお母さんは水商売をしていて
昼間は寝ていて 夜は出て行く
たまの休みに家にいると
お酒を飲んで大暴れするんだそうです
そんな彼と私が出会ったのは
彼が15歳 中学校３年生の頃
最初は目も見ず 下を向いて
話もしませんでした
今では 少しずつ良くなって16歳
中学校を卒業して
私の会社に勤めて
私の会社の寮で暮らして
私と一緒に仕事をしています
そんな関係性ですので
彼とは２人っきりになることがよくあります
この間 何気なしに彼に
「おい １つだけ願いが叶うとしたら
何がいい？」って聞いてみました
彼はこんなすごい髪の色して
やんちゃで元気な子だから
「俺 バイクが欲しいっす」とか
「単車が欲しいっす」って言うって
俺は 想像してたんだけれども
彼の口から出た言葉は
「おばあちゃんに会いたいです」
一体 どうしてこんなことが
起こってしまうんでしょうか？
大好きなおばあちゃんがいなくなって
親も愛してくれない
生きるって本当に
素晴らしいことなんでしょうか？
A君 —
彼は 小さい頃から
虐待を受けていました
ある日は 布団で寝ていると
上からお父さんにいきなり殴られ
鼻の骨が折れたこともあるそうです
ある日は お母さんが殴られ
ある日は お兄ちゃんが殴られる
家族中が 恐怖で震えていたそうです
彼は男の子だから
お母さんが目の前で殴られるのを見て
どうしても許せなかったけど
怖くて何もできなかった
手も足も出なかった
そんな勇気のない自分を
ただただ責める毎日を過ごしていました
そんな彼が お父さんから
よく言われていた言葉は
「お前なんて いなくていい」
子供は 大人の言うことを
まっすぐ受け止めます
だから彼は
「俺はこの世に必要のない人間なんだ」
「もしかしたら生きていることが
罪なんだ」と感じてしまったそうです
そんな彼が21歳の頃
隣人からの通報で
お父さんが捕まりました
そしてお母さんは
自分と１番年上の妹を置いて
どっかに消えてしまいました
突如に訪れた 妹と自分の２人の生活
何から―
何をしていいか分からない
頭は真っ白
不安で押し潰されそうになりながらも
１つだけ 希望ができたそうです
その希望は 目をつぶったら
すべてが終わって楽になれないか？
彼は 自殺願望を
抱くようになっていました
それでも 自分がいなくなった後の
妹のことを思うと 妹が心配で
死ぬことはできませんでした
じゃあ一体 彼が
何をしたっていうんでしょうか？
こんなにひどい仕打ちを受けてもなお
妹のことを心配して
死ねない彼のその優しさは
なんで報われねぇんだよ？
そして 彼らに共通して言えるのは
親から愛されることを期待して
裏切られたということ
裏切られることは痛いから こりごりだから
だったらもう何もいらない
そうやって 心が空っぽになっていくんです
僕と同じような活動をしている仲間から
こんなことを聞いたことがあります
幼少期に虐待を受けている子供は
必ずと言っていいほど
お母さんに会いたい お父さんに会いたいって
言うようになるそうです
子供はただただ
親から愛して欲しいんです
こんな子供たちがたくさんいるということを
受け止めて欲しいと思います
そして 彼らはお母さんに
お父さんに愛を求めながら
こんなことを思います
「殴られたのは 自分が言うことを
聞かないからだ 悪い子だからだ」
「お前なんかいらねぇって言われたのは
自分が他の子より 劣っているからだ」
「もっと頑張んなきゃいけないんだ」
だけど そんなの絶対間違ってんだよ
おかしいのは大人たちなんだよ
だって 自ら望んで
生まれてきたわけじゃねぇだんべ
そして ここからは大人たちの
みなさんに話したいと思います
日本の子供の数は 約1,605万人
児童虐待の相談件数と
児童養護施設に預けられている子供の数
合わせてみると約15万人
つまり おおよそ 100人に1人の子供は
親からまともな愛情を
受けていないことになるんです
こんなに大きな問題なのに
社会的関心は低く
知らない人もたくさんいる
これってちょっとおかしいと思いませんか？
だって 今 あなたの目と鼻の先で
涙を流している子供たちがいるんです
その現実を まずは受け止めてください
そして ここからは人間だけが
唯一使える能力を使ってください
それは 想像です
明日の世界を または未来を
創っていくのは子供たちです
その明日の世界を創る
子供たちの100人に1人が
まともな環境下で育っていなければ
この国はどうなるでしょうか？
簡単に想像ができます
そして 想像ができたなら
やるべきことは簡単です
今すぐにでも
自分ん家の子供 お孫さん
今より少し深く愛してください
そして同時に 自分ん家以外の子供
子供の友達でもいい
愛してやってください
今よりもっと目を凝らして
見てやってください
そっと 声をかけてあげてください
そんな些細な行動が
子供にとっては
一生心に残る 嬉しい体験になるんです
確かに たった１人の力では
世界は変えられないかもしれない
だけれども たった１人の力で
１人の子供の世界は
変えてあげることができるんです
もっと知って欲しい
子供の傷の深さを
私たちの無知がもたらす悲劇を
そして 私たち大人たちが 子供たちを
救ってあげられるということを
100人に1人の子供
これを悲劇と思うか
また捉え方を変えて
100人に1人 たくさんいるからこそ
今より少しだけでも注意をして
子供たちを見る
そして 心配な子がいれば
声をかけてあげる
それだけで たくさんの子供を
救ってあげることができるんです
このアイディアが今日 僕から
大人たちへ送りたいギフトです
そして ここからは
今も１人ぼっちを感じてる
みんなに話したいと思う
みんなは不幸になるために
生まれてきたんじゃない
幸せになるために
生まれてきたはずなんだ
今はまだ分からないかもしれない
どれだけ自分が素晴らしいかってことを
だけど 絶対幸せになるはずなんだ
本当のことを話すと
今日 今 この時間が来るまで
俺は 自分の子供の頃のことなんか
話したくなかった
だって 真冬の朝５時半に 校門の前で
体育座りをしている子供は 普通じゃない
分かってる
こんな話をしたら みんなから
変に優しくされるんじゃないかとか
特別な目で見られるんじゃないかと思うと
ずっと怖かった
たぶん 初めて俺のことを見た人は
何にも悩みなんかなさそうだし
丈夫そうだし
そんな風に見えると思う
そういう風に 着飾って生きてきた
そういう風にしてないと
今まで積み上げてきたものが
全部なくなっちゃいそうで怖かった
みんなと同じで 怖かった
だけど 毎日みんなのことを考えると
みんなの心の傷が
自分の傷のように思えて
もう見てらんねぇから
勇気を振り絞って
今日ここで話をしに来ました
今日の俺の姿を見て
少しでも勇気を持てたなら
心が震えたとすれば
今度は みんなが苦しんでる仲間を
応援してやって欲しい
今にも負けそうになっている仲間を
助けてやれるのは みんなだけなんだ
だって彼らの中には
自分の姿があるんだから
生まれてからずっと
嫌なことばっかりだったかもしれない
今もそうかもしれない
だけど そのおかげで
俺たちには特別な能力が宿っている
声なき声が聞こえる
耳を澄ますと
「お母さん 抱っこしてよ」
「お父さん 運動会に来てよ」
そんな声が聞こえてくる
自分と同じ痛み
どれだけ痛いか本当によく分かる
今 みんなに
与えてもらえる幸せがねぇんだったら
与えてあげられる幸せを感じて
生きていけばいいんだよ
そしたら 与えてたはずの幸せが
いつか君の心をきっと 幸せな気持ちで
いっぱいにする日が来るから
俺もそうだった
自分が出会った子供たちを
なんとか幸せにしてやりてぇと思って
活動を続けてきたけど
気付いてみたら 自分が毎日幸せになってた
こういう幸せになり方も
あるんだってことを
このアイディアが今日
俺からみんなへのギフトです
そして最後に
大人たちを代表して
みんなに謝りたいと思う
もし今みんなが
悲しい思いをしているんだったら
生きている価値さえ
見つけられないんであれば
それは君たちのせいじゃない
他でもない
すべて大人たちの責任なんです
本当にごめんなさい
そして 絶対 幸せになってね
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）